うぇっ..
ああっ!!
鬱陶しい...
もう、髪の毛が長いし金髪が飽きてきました
はじめしゃちょーです
ひょっとしたら、もうすぐもう金髪辞めるんで
今のうちに
スクショしといて（人´∀`*）
皆さんは～
食パッッンッ!!ヲタベマスカ？
食パッッンッ!!
....
食パッ...!
まぁまぁまぁ、様々な食パンが世の中にはありますよ
「Pasco」の「超熟」とかね
あ！これも聞く！
フジパン本仕込だ！
「ダブルソフト」とか
これもなんか昔からあるっぽいな～
なんか雰囲気的に
「ヤマザキパン」の..
ほぼ「ヤマザキ」じゃね!?!?
ほぼ「ヤマザキ」じゃね!?
世の中にはいろんな食パンがあるわけなんです
まぁまぁまぁ、俺みたいにねっ！
新世界の
王
神
となると
uh..
俺みたいに神となると
食べ物のね、微妙な違いにも気づくんすよ
食パンの味を僕がね、何か当てます
いまから
これによってねやっぱ、俺のねステータスというか
食べ物のちいさな細かい違い？
味のわかる男になるわけですよっ!!
今までいろんなね、なんかこういうのやってるんですけども～
ほぼ失敗に終わってます
今回は決めるぜ!!!
ではいこう!!!!
こちらの6種類
ふんわり食パン
超熟
ダブルソフト
やわらか仕込み
ロイヤルブレット
本仕込
やわらかが二つあるな～...
あ、ちゃう..
「ふんわり」と「やわらか」だ
じゃあさっそく味見タイムです！
ふんわり食パンから!
ふんわりていうくらいだからわかりやすいと思うので
いただきます
あ～ふんわりしてる
食パンって基本的に味があんまりないんで
小さな味を覚えて～
俺は今日、勝ちに行きます
ほんのり甘いな...
超熟
ちょっと硬いかな～？
香ばしい
香ばしいな
ふんわりはちょっと甘かったｊ〇※∨△
こっちは香ばしいぞ
あんまり甘くない
ちょっと大人な味ですね
超熟は
ダブルソフト
あ～柔らかい
柔らかい
えっ
謎
一番何もないわ
ダブルソフトは
何にもないぞ・・・
ただちょっとねえ
なんか
ぃっ・・・
ぁぁぁあああ！
やわらか仕込み
やわらか仕込みだけ
トップバリューのやつです
じゃ、いただきます
ええ・・・？
えぇぇ？？
ぅあぁ...なんか給食に出そう
給食......
給食感がありますねぇ
次
ロイヤルブレッド
食パンの耳を食べるから
だめなんだなあ
中を
中を感じよう
んぁあ...
こぉれはぁ
無理かもしれない
いやぁっ
そんなことねーぞ
un.........
全部同じだ...
フジパンの本仕込ぃ
いきます！
フジパン本仕込
はぁあっ
おなぁぁあ
まってぇ
たぶんねぇ
微妙な違いはあるかもしんないけど
やっぱ同じだよぉ～
なにが違うって言うのぉ～？
ちょ、待って
ほんｔ...
ちょ、今回笑えないわ
今回やばい
ほんっとにわかんない
ちょともう一周します
やっぱ、本仕込おいしいのかなあ
これうめえぞ
多分
本仕込はおいしいです
で！
後のもおいしいです
ぜんぶ　おいしい
俺これ大丈夫かなあ......
各食パンが分かりやすいように
えっと～....
目印をつけました
このコップに食パンを入れて
僕が目隠しをして
これは何かを当てます！
ちょっ...最初味見チェック
もうちょっと味見させてください
優しいんだよ
ふんわり...
ふんわりは優しい
超熟はちょっと苦い
ま、でもね、
量均等にしなきゃ
なんかあれだ...
不正とか言われそう
全部同じくらいの量でしょ？
全部同じぐらいの量だよなぁ？
よしっ
バッチリだ！
当てたら俺本物だぞぉ
俺は今回
三度も味見した
以前とは違うからな
いくぞっ
あ、もう
見えてませんからね
よし、じゃあ　行きます！
SHUFFLE START！
ぁぁぁぁああああああぁあぁあぁあ！！！！！！！！
あれ...？？
落ちた落ちた....
あったあった...あった......
よし...
整いました～
では！
じゃっ、これから
これからいきます
これからいきまーす
ふぅ......
first impression
あっ！
あっ！...
これわかるかも...！
いただきます
あっ
あっっ....
わかる...
ぅあっ...！
え、待って
あれでしょ、これ...
あれだ
ふんわり食パン！！
全部同じ！！！！
ん...？
あっ...
ロイヤルブレッド！
三個目ロイヤルブレッドです
食った瞬間わかった